hi welcome to alternative views
tonight's program we'll look at the less
majestic side of the law in the United
States our program entitled tonight is
the American police state and with us to
discuss the problem we have in an encore
performance back with us again John
Duncan the head of the Texas ACLU
welcome and with us to discuss a couple
stories in their lives
Barbara Hines from the Legal Aid Society
will talk about her efforts to obtain a
dossier compiled by the FBI on her the
interesting story and we also have Jim
Lutz from AC TV working with them for
the last three years we have some
interesting film of last year's boat
race on Town Lake where it led to a
chicago-style police riot but before we
get to that as usual we'll go to the
news and Frank and Al and the rest of
the folks here's a headline you don't
see on television nowadays or even in
the regular newspapers but the National
Enquirer has a gas crisis as a big hoax
and unlike the other story up on top
here which says how to avoid traffic
tickets which tells you basically don't
break the law and don't slash the cops
the gas crisis being a big hoax is
backed up with some statistics and some
opinions from high-level people who
should know for instance a quote doctor
James Patterson who's an economist and
oil industry expert from the University
of Indiana is saying it's a hoax he uses
American Petroleum Institute figures to
prove it he says the US gasoline stocks
stand at two hundred fifty nine point
six million barrels twelve million
barrels more than 1977 when there was no
crisis crude oil stocks are three three
hundred and five million barrels three
thirty two point seven million more than
two years ago and that a man for gas is
only risen a tiny bit only point at
three percent and even according to
Central Intelligence Agency's latest
estimates there's more oil gas and
petroleum products in the u.s. pipeline
at any time in history that didn't
enough there are other people who chimed
in professor Fred singer Energy
economist from University of Virginia
and a former high ranking
your Department official said that these
figures show that the oil crisis is a
blatant fraud and senator Howard
Metzenbaum a democratic IOT's that's the
same thing the oil companies are trying
to hold on to their oil as long as
possible and wait for the highest price
they can get they're trying to frighten
the American public just to run up the
prices
it's interesting to note Frank that the
the big three reported last night on TV
the gasoline reserves are actually down
I said I wish they'd get together with
mr. Rowe what's his face there and also
their own outfit the American Petroleum
Institute well there are others who they
have also quoted a statistics editor
from the oil and gas general an attorney
for independent oil companies president
of consumer Energy Council for America
and other people the GAO for instance
the General Accounting Office all say
the same thing and then in addition to
this they made a survey of Germany
England Switzerland and France various
people from spokesmen of auto clubs to
people who are in a Ministry of
International Trade and Industry in
Tokyo for instance or various high-level
agencies they say we're not feeling any
crisis we're not scared what's the big
panic in the United States I guess it's
the panic to the bank
well hey we've talked about quite collar
crime remember a while back we were
talking about some of the pats on the
wrist which some of the rich people get
if they're caught in the cookie jar
misdeeds yes that's right miss Deane
we've got to understand those poor folks
right my well-meaning people well here's
another one
they're the federal grand jury in
Houston is looking to a couple of small
oil companies who were involved in the
oil scam what they were doing was
fraudulently converting barrels of old
oil into new oil and selling them at a
$6 price over the regular price and the
one guy who's head of the company made
4.4 million dollars on this well he
under plea bargain arrangement he agreed
to refund 3.2 million if they would drop
the charges against him write it off as
a business expense to Annette's 800,000
my pen yeah that's like you stealing the
thousand dollars from me in the in the
court saying well that's okay
payback 600 yeah payback 600 we'll call
it even with the interesting thing about
this is if i moto don't realize that the
major oil firms which are vertically
integrated have been doing this for
years they're passing costs forward so
it goes on the corporate books as a cost
but actually it's increasing their cash
flow this is something we did talk about
an alternative use the bleep last year
but this is what the Arabs are also
saying that big oil companies are doing
right now
they bought a lot of oil under the old
contracts the old price and they're
selling it on the independent or spot
oil market at considerably higher prices
up to twenty four dollars a barrel yeah
well you have a couple of things there
too well Frank we have a swine flu
updates what we have here something a
lot of us would prefer to forget I'm
sorry we we don't have our visuals you
know down pat today because there's an
actual there's a beautiful photographs
of Jerry Ford with this moronic grin on
his face
getting the swine flu shot and
essentially replaces right this is from
the Journal of Insurance so typical of
government spending we have a hundred
and thirty five million dollar program
that is ballooned into a three billion
dollar disaster as of last year of
in terms of the the deadline for filing
for claims on swine flu
there are 278 claims for wrongful death
totaling about 300 million dollars and
3,000 claims for personal injuries of
not the least of which is the what is
the barre syndrome people get about 95%
paralysis from this totaling almost
almost three billion dollars in claims
the original estimates of the claims
against the government were something in
the order of one to two billion dollars
so again the insurance industry has a
has fallen a little short on their
estimates but here we have a program is
supposed to benefit the health of the
people and instead we have people
croaking dying getting paralyzed and
ensuing the government for three billion
dollars now if you remember back during
the swine flu program the private
insurance sector wouldn't touch this
thing with a ten-foot pole part of the
bill to provide funding for the major
drug companies is that they remove any
liability from the drug companies for
the issuance of the swine flu the other
thing in the news is actually a
contradiction between the Wall Street
Journal's not a contradiction but it's
kind of I guess the difference in tastes
or difference in reporting styles on
corporate profits in the Wall Street
Journal today we have corporate profits
after taxes surged nine point six
percent not as in Samak a whole lot nine
points nine point six percent that's
actually what they're talking about and
if you read the article in detail
they're talking about from quarter to
quarter of course what we heard on the
news last night what we have from the AP
source is that actually corporate
profits over the year increased twenty
six point four percent and this is the
largest increase since 1950 after-tax
profits soared twenty five point two
percent but here's what some of the
people in power are saying about this I
think is rather interesting the very
large increases in profits of American
corporations will strengthen the
widespread belief that many American
businesses aren't assuming their full
responsibilities to invite inflation
this is Alfred con-con also has coated
on the evening news as saying something
to the effect that we're high profits
necessarily by themselves are not bad
but if they're caused by high prices
then he sort of trailed off Lyle Graham
Lee who is a member of the Council and
economic advisor says it makes us wonder
if the business community is taking
seriously the guidelines we have put
into place to hold prices in check now
khan has promised that he will published
a list of names of corporations who were
going higher than usual profits I'm
certain uncertain that that will that
will offend them so that they'll reduce
their prices
he has also pointed out that most large
corporations seemed to be in compliance
with the guidelines the primary
offenders are small businesses Elysee
and medium-sized firms Jack you got a
couple of goodies to do you know yeah
I've got a few here I wasn't going to
appear on today's show but a friend gave
me a few did that my friend gave me this
particular article that appeared in the
money in Monday's Texan written by a
clown named Mark Dooley it's under day
the column of reporter's notebook it is
probably one of the most misogynist
pieces I've ever seen in any that's
woman-hating by the way in anything any
print or electronic media let me read
just a little bit of this twerp my
father has this Bobby Riggs theory that
things in general have been going
downhill at an alarming rate
ever since women got the vote after
giving the idea considerable thought for
six minutes I must concur well the
article goes downhill from here he's
capable of thought for six minutes I
think that speaks for himself well he
said the problem is basically that quote
women have just gotten too damn uppity
taketake Millette for example please he
adds Henny Youngman everybody back in
the 40s of course and he talks about
Kate Millett exposed recent expulsion by
the ayatollah khomeini from iran and he
says three cheers for the Ayatollah
chalk one up for the good guys gals and
get back in the kitchen or get pregnant
to go on I really don't want to belabor
this point he's not worth it a problem
he says that in America today the
Shannon Alexander's and the Jane Fonda's
and the Barbara Walters and alike
indicate that we have a quote high
threshold for mindless women and
ignorant [ __ ] this is what further he
has to say this is revolting I
understand
and what this country needs is an
Ayatollah or two off with their heads
the fundus syndrome will kill us all
now if I've done you wrong mr. Dooley
and what you meant with satire then I
apologize for impugning your character
but it's your writing style then because
you're not in the in the same classes
dan Aykroyd or John Belushi in my book
and are part of the not ready for any
time players and they're not all that
sure and they're not all that sharpie
that's witnessed a couple weeks ago with
their women's problems but let's let's
bring it closer closer to home rather
let me let me talk about Sameer Iran
since we're talking about Iran in women
this is something from the revolutionary
regime in Iran which I few weeks ago
applauded their coming to power and I
still believe so but they need to get
their act together over there an
unmarried couple Court having sexual
relations were publicly flogged in the
Caspian Sea town of a mesh for refusing
orders by Revolutionary authorities to
get married she got a hundred lashes
he got twenty five but lest we leave you
on to salary note we have some good guys
in the news will have to give you some
happy news this is our Charles Kuralt
story of the week here a Hampshire
college student that's in Amherst
Massachusetts was fired from his job in
the College cafeteria it seems he was
required for refusing to obey orders to
dock to stop doing such things as
writing no nukes in carrot sticks on top
of the salads and making hammer and
sickle designs in the wax on the cottage
cheese says David Bates
23 I was only trying to break up the
board I'm on the job and provide some
enjoyment for the cafeteria patrons
keep it up David wherever you're going
to be in your next employments really if
you ever in Texas David you can come and
join us here on alternative views I
guess they don't let him drink tomato
juice because it's red
red tape red tape
here's one that I know what's going to
do to the tobacco industry but there's a
study has been made in Alabama that the
there's a high incident rate of southern
women of mouth cancer because so many
Southern women dip snuff and chew
tobacco just take a little pinch put
cream cheek and goon
yeah good cancer in about 15 years
there's a an interesting thing going
around now John you might have a comment
on this it's called people are calling a
gray male not black male degree male
there are three different stories that
come in and tie this together a perjury
case against Edward Garrity the senior
vice president of ITT was dropped by the
Justice Department because it feared the
disclosure of national security
information he'd been accused of lying
about ITT's role in the 1970 Chilean
presidential election of course with a
great deal of connection very close
connection cooperation with the CIA and
then about the same time there was a
case that was dropped against a
Singapore banker who had been accused of
bilking millions of dollars from
investors in California but the charges
against him were dropped also because he
had a special relationship with the CIA
and now in the nation they're talking
about the same thing might occur in this
in the suit against Patrick gray and
other eff high FBI officials they're
saying that the several well-placed
sources confide that the prosecution of
these men who are accused of ordering
burglaries and private homes might be
dropped to avoid exposing secret
information in court John is there as a
part of a trend the March 20th Dallas
Morning News has a little story about
along the same line Attorney General
Bell has had a contempt citation yeah
that's what ending against in for some
months now for refusal to disclose FBI
informants and who did a lot of the
burglary of the Socialist Workers Party
Socialist Workers Party has a 40 million
dollar lawsuit pending against the US
government
for surveillance that went back into the
1930s and they never showed a violation
of law at any time with any of this
stuff there were numerous instances in
which the FBI illegally broke in in an
attempt to enter discovery order a
federal district judge ordered the
Attorney General to turn over these
records and Attorney General Bell
refused again it's the national security
protection of the informant the Second
Circuit now has reported on March 20th
has removed that contempt order and said
there are other ways that you can pursue
this basically the other way is to drop
the charge in default - and allow the
taxpayers to pay about 40 million
dollars to the Socialist Workers rather
than to present the information and what
you wind up with is taxpayers paying for
the incompetence and the crimes
committed by public officials in damages
back to individuals well what can we do
you suppose I guess not a heck of a lot
we'll keep looking here for a good story
I can't find one so I guess I better
close with a quote from Ambrose Bierce
this is dedicated not only to President
Carter but also a to our last several
presidents Ambrose Bierce epigram was he
whose lies no longer deceived has
forfeited the right to tell the truth
Jack shall we get to yeah let me maybe
lay some historical grounding for
discussion of the American police state
an inequality of enforcement of the law
in 1895 the Supreme Court in one year
rules minimum wage laws unconstitutional
violation of free contract they also in
rule that the income tax was class
legislation and also unconstitutional
but turned around and ruled that the
Sherman Antitrust Act which did not
apply to manufacturing companies did
apply to labor unions well if you think
that's part of the sort of just sorted
see me passed that we have come of age
as a country and we long we now conduct
our politics and our lives more
aboveboard and now in the post-watergate
morality and the like that we with
sunshine laws the commitment to equal
justice well think again we have some
interesting people here tonight to
discuss that these are this is not part
of Jarre past that this continues today
and john i think you're going to bring
us up to date and some of the
contemporary forms of repression in this
country all right
i suppose when we think of the police
state we tend to think of federal
government FBI the abysus of the Nixon
administration there are classic
examples of a movement toward a police
state but what I really want to start
off on today was some of the things that
are pending before the Texas Legislature
because this stuff would not go on if
you did nothin some session create a
public environment in which the public
agrees to get up certain constitutional
rights most of the time without thinking
very seriously about it our previous
governor Dolph Brisco had as many of you
will recall a law-and-order packaged her
anti-crime package in the 1977
legislative session if you looked at
that package on a piece by piece basis
and put it together it had most of the
provisions and if you would have gotten
in Senate bail one son
Senate bill 1 yeah our sign of Senate
bill 1 during the last legislative
session first cousins
help first code whatever but what we're
experiencing now and I'll have to say we
were reasonably successful in making
most of the proposals in the Briscoe the
Briscoe package basically meaningless
they got through the session last time
is the whole thing is reappeared now
what we've got is retreaded Dolph
Briscoe law-and-order with governor bill
limits signature across it
last week he unchangeable parts you
notice this it doesn't matter introduced
our put out a press statement saying on
many occasions I have stated I am for
strong and effective law enforcement the
recommend that the legislature dropped
adopt measures that will enable local
district and state law enforcement
officials to do a better job and then he
starts listing off bills which he will
support as part of a law-and-order
package an examination of those bills
shows that what you have coming back is
essentially the same thing at a very
conservative legislature rejected in
1977 insofar as the proposals are
concerned you've got electronic
eavesdropping again we scream drugs
crime this sort of thing and suddenly we
hand to the police the tool which they
can go in and legally invade everyone's
privacy forget about the Fourth
Amendment forget about the Fifth
Amendment just let them go in and listen
to everyone this is enly do the
evidentiary sir table that is a second
one it goes from electronic surveillance
to evidentiary search warrants Texas has
a good search warrant law one of the
best in the country in terms of
protecting individual rights we do not
have any broad-based search warrants
based upon the fact that mere evidence
might be found that a crime might have
been committed which essentially would
allow any police officer in anybody's
door that's what these people want and
here it comes back in exactly the same
form oral confessions last legislative
session the governor finally pushed
through an oral confession
law after we in the criminal defense
lawyers Association managed to tag some
safeguards on it it said basically that
if an oral confession is to be
introduced
it must be tape recorded in the presence
of at least two people and the tape must
show the person who is making this
confession being warned that it is being
taped that it will be introduced in
court that it will be used against them
and that it can be introduced only if
that person takes the stand and makes a
statement they contradict something that
is said on that tape it's something that
protects any individual against getting
a confession beat out of them and then
having a police officer say well this is
what he said what you've got over there
now is a bill that goes back to what
they proposed last time and that is any
police officer can get on the stand and
square that so-and-so said such and such
and confessed to this crime and in
effect put the police officer on the
stand to testify against the defendant
and allege that it was the defendants
words Texas has a provision that
prohibits the state to appeal our from
appealing in a criminal case it's
something that keeps a particular
vicious DA who's got something in from
so for somebody from as soon as he loses
his case running into court and
appealing it and continuing to arrest
the individual is the gentleman locked
it up around Dallas wasn't there a guy
who had about 2000 of his convictions
overturned the one of the local DA's up
there I believe four haranguing
witnesses and stuff flowers Dallas
County has a very high rate in terms of
convictions being overturned by our
prosecutorial misconduct in the
courtroom which but I didn't win either
if your train of thought but what about
the practice of a lot of JPS of keeping
a batch of search warrants you know on
hand for cops to use anytime anywhere
well is on the books we've got a good
search warrant on what you the problem
that you've got is with JPS and
municipal judges who very often will
sign any search warrant without really
sitting down and
having a full probable cause hearing
they sign the warrant and police
officers then go in and search place to
air place apart the worst parts of these
abuses occurred routinely back in the
early 70s on the anti-war people in
which they would allege possession
America narcotics and go in and just
tear somebody's apartment they started
they you know sorry you know is there
any way we can safeguard this to do this
put a listing of civil rights or Bill of
Rights or something up on the Jay peace
wall so you can at least look at it
before you know routinely signs I mean
aren't they supposed to do some sort of
research before they sign these things
well ideally they should but as a
practical matter it's very difficult you
know I'm always really suspicious when
they say well you know don't worry about
this repressive law because we're going
to go to court and we're going to have a
jug oh you don't have a judge say it's
alright yeah that sets up I've seen
people in the world or judges the most
abusive of civil rights or justice
you've got that problem with the
wiretapping bill they'll always come in
and say this has got safeguards in it it
will require a judge's signature and
this provides adequate safeguards well
perfect example of the fact that there
can be no adequate safeguards is the
fact that in Texas at the moment to
install a wiretap is a third degree
felony is a federal felony unless there
has been an order issued to a federal
agent by a federal judge it means that
no police officers in Texas no sheriff's
can legally install wiretapping if they
do so they commit a federal felony
well the Houston Police Department has
on a number of occasions had officers
indicted under federal law for violating
that and we've just seen the charges
against the sheriff up if learning he's
an idol to be presumed innocent unless
proven guilty but federal charges have
been brought against him saying that he
was going out to install a wiretap now
if Commission of a federal felony he
wasn't even there and commission of a
federal felony is not sufficient to keep
people from doing this
certainly no safe guard is going to
exist by getting a judge to sign the
thing
first you mentioned something before the
show started also about this bill that
had something to do with the Department
of Public Safety which i think is very
interesting well that's one of the worst
bills that's been introduced over there
in a long time hello excuse me who
introduces this so it's nice to have
names besides these violation downs
Mazzetti and Ohio State Senator from
Fort Worth has a known Senate side
Senate belfort Kane Carlisle Smail state
representative from Grand Prairie hazard
on the house side House bill 64 this
would set the Department of Public
Safety up as an eight ace pre-employment
screener for private employers it would
set them up as a pre credit screener for
banks mortgage companies your various
credit bureaus
my detector tests the home it does not
do lie-detector test what it is is a
criminal record system in which those
who have a need to know not the press
they have no need to know under this
bill those who are entering into a
private business transaction in which
money will be exchanging hands either
through a payment of wages are through
loans or any other commercial
transaction are those who contemplate
such relationships may buy from the
Department of Public Safety arrest
record information my guest on a daily
basis so that it would be possible for
these private security firms just to
have a blank check deposited with DPS
and on a daily basis take ever arrest
record valid or not regardless of its
position and place it in their own
private computers and use this as a
gigantic blacklist in terms of screening
public employees these companies that do
this investigation deal in dirt on
people the more dirt that they can turn
up in the more hysteria they can
generate with employers the more
contracts that they're going to get and
what they you would do is say I were
pulled over coming down the freeway
driving my little yellow Toyota somebody
else has been
and charged or there's a police radio
thing going out so-and-so
in a yellow Toyota Rob such-and-such
Bank they pull you over they you Begley
fit the description they haul you in
they fingerprint you and the whole bit
bit run you in to DPS to see whether or
not you've got a record the record is
created there and used against you in
your employment then for the rest of
your life you would have that thing
following you around though they might
cut you loose the next morning saying
arrested armed robbery it's the worst
thing that's been introduced in a long
time I think it's the thing that
aggravates me is that we pay the
salaries of these Yahoo's who passed
this kind of garbage or try to pass this
kind of garbage but I asked my wife if
she's paid her bank payments this month
because I certainly don't wanna get
pulled over okay John you did mention
that there is something that law doesn't
exist exist divorce for public climate
and how do you explain the ability of
law enforcement officials and
politicians in there apparently blank
check that the public hands over to them
in terms of it's a matter of laws are
creating a hysterical climate we've got
a crime problem in this society and
nobody's going to deny that but we also
have a legal system that is designed to
protect the rights of the innocent to
protect the average citizen see to it
that the police do not run rampant over
everyone and from time to time you will
get political figures who are able to
manipulate public fear much of that fear
is justified with crime levels in some
communities are very great and there are
some areas of the country where a person
cannot walk the streets lately and you
get opportunistic politicians Nixon was
a perfect example Agnew when he was
there in terms of the law and order type
thing
the Briscoe appeal was essentially of
the same variety in terms of his law and
order program in which the public fears
are manipulated and the threat of
physical violence to any one individual
is greatly exaggerated a attitude of
public fear is created and at that point
then you run it into the legislature in
a semi historical environment and
anybody who opposes some of this just
based on basic constitutional provisions
is thought then to be soft on law and
order one of the things I've always
thought is one of the chief culprits
especially here in alternative views
it's appropriate for us to mention when
the chief culprits in mobilizing public
opinion to support these kind of
repressive laws is the media which talks
every night about murders and killings
and rapes and muggings but really
doesn't give a context to understand or
pawns off as being just sociological
do-gooders to talk about what are the
roots of crime in the first place let me
ask you the head of the tech Texas ACLU
take a couple minutes what's the roots
of crime tell our audience Tony tell us
a whole lot of it I would argue is
economically and sociologically based if
you look at who winds up in the Texas
Department of Corrections
it's basically those who come from poor
families from minority families those
whose mineral capacity is not as great
as the average citizen those that are
essentially the left out of society and
programs that are designed to assist
people of this variety routinely get
knocked down in terms of more welfare
more giveaways destroying incentives and
what have you the human needs human
resources sector of the budget is the
one that is always the last to be funded
I think you put your finger on it right
there our remember reading in the
Philadelphia Inquirer a few years ago
that after the riots in Philadelphia
which is based on that central city
problem and the people there eventually
poor relatively poor any way you want to
call it instead of coming in and helping
people remodel homes people don't like
to live in housing projects basically if
they own something of course we'll take
care of it instead of putting money into
that sort of thing they came in and gave
the police tanks armed crushers shields
they put money into the police part of
it but no money into the economic
development part but part of that too
little too is part of the too little too
late closing the bun door after the
horse is gone the ends up costing
actually if you're interested in fiscal
conservatism ends up costing you more
money the failure to have sort of
minimum income maintenance in this
country which might come to a family of
four about eight thousand dollars if we
took sort of a McGovern proposal and
ends up with costing $15,000 to keep
them independent of men in a
penitentiary isn't no we were talking
about violation of civil liberties and
the police running rampant and you
mentioned the Socialist Workers Party
all about hello we have Barbara Hines
with us and Barbara's going to tell us
about her situation and relationship
with the FBI and a dossier that was
compiled on on her we frequently hear
about these and but we really usually
don't have an opportunity to hear
first-hand from somebody actually went
through it can you tell us a bit about
your experience well I started looking
for Maya
yah-ha
Norvel and ms magazines and there was
also an article and mother jones which
is another left-wing magazine that the
FBI had kept massive dossier eyes on
people that were active in politics in
the 60s so several friends of mine and
myself just decided why not to send off
and we sort of laughed about the party
we would have we agreed to all open our
files together and things of that sort
we did it under the Freedom of
Information Act which under the law it's
the friend of Information Act Privacy
Act a federal statute you are supposed
to get information within ten days in
order to get my hundred page FBI file it
took nine months and the first letter
that I got back from the FBI said thank
you for your request and your support
and then it said your your request has
been assigned number twenty nine
thousand I don't know what we are now
processing requests from a year ago and
really there have been so many people
that have taken advantage of this raw I
don't think anyone that ever passed it
the legislators that drafted that law
ever thought that there would be the
public use of the Freedom of Information
Act that there is now so about nine
months later I got a letter saying that
if I want to send them ten dollars per
100 pages that they were sending my FBI
file and basically some of it is routine
civil service employment a lot of it is
a lot of surveillance that went on in
the 60s
Tenzing barber what led you to believe
there was a filing in the first place
but I just did it just because I read
that they then I was very I was very
very involved in the women's movement
here in the 60s when they were about ten
and was running man talking about
women's liberation at the University and
everybody thought we were crazy I also
worked on the rag which was an
undergraduate paper and I was involved
in anti-war
here in the 60s and so I just thought I
write off and in some ways I thought
sure they probably did surveilling and
we always thought there were informants
and the movements were involved in but
they were afraid it was paranoia back
then but it was vinyl and then of course
everything we thought was true the
conclusion of my case was that I was
classified as disloyal number three the
government has a four-point-oh oil tea
scale the first as I remember I did a
lot of research into this because I did
in a feel and I asked that my file be
expunged and basically after six months
I did agree to expunge my file though
I'm not sure it's ever going to be done
the way I got a letter saying they were
going to do it they're going to the army
computer bankers you know the catch-22
on that is if you write them and ask
them for your file and they don't have
one they use that letter court 100 or
they send back sometimes if you will we
will search our records if you will tell
us the times and the place is what you
think you were under surveillance I've
heard that some of the stuff involves
newspaper clipping some of it involves
maybe insurance information they have
access to the insurance information
whereby if you've ever asked for auto
insurance or something insurance agent
or life insurance insurance that you may
come around and he'll ask your neighbors
if you know this person said well we
don't know him but we know that his
lights are on all night you know which
what the hell does that mean I mean some
of the information can be innocuous some
of the information is just pure gossip
because yours like that was any of yours
like that it was a real hardcore
surveillance no there are two things the
first was I applied for a civil service
job with the Internal Revenue
service and they did a routine security
investigation but under the law when
loyalty of an employee is suspect is the
loyalties questions it converts into a
full field operation investigation
that's what they did in my case in
addition to that not in apply for this
job full field means they actually come
in and ask all your neighbors down the
same questions they have about 10 pages
on all of my parents friends in
Brownsville where I went to high school
they went to all sorts of professor's
friends I mean it is really incredible
the amount of information that they
gathered and the waste of money and that
is probably the most incredible thing
then they also have information starting
from 1969 through 1972 which is my
political activities nothing involves
any breaking of law I mean it was sort
of free speech that I went to a
demonstration they had things they knew
what meetings I went to how many people
were at the meetings then they have a
little statement that women's liberation
is an organization I can remember what
they said dedicated to the overthrow of
male chauvinism and being dirty FBI
agents idea was of what women's
liberation was then so as to guilt by
association
there was nothing in this file that I
was a member of the next five pages of
organizations in which they defined SDS
progressive labor every left-wing
organization around in the 60s so that
in case you wanted to know about all
these other things that is also in my at
the author where this ranking number
three me well I wish I had had I brought
my phone I did a lot of legal research
on it when I was writing my appeal to
the Department of Justice number one are
people that are known communists or
anarchists or members of subversive
organizations to I think are people that
associate or belong to organizations
that our communist or in our history
subversive oriented and then three are
people that are seen at these meetings
something of the sort I can't exactly
remember or associate with people who
are supposed to be communist excuse me
we're with the ACLU come in on the top
outwardly we've been involved in some of
this in fact the DPS was involved in the
same sort of thing now Colonel Speer is
on record over in the federal court is
saying that none of that was ever
authorized and that had all been
destroyed you had all horizons been
destroyed which means not had the suit
that we brought on behalf of an airline
pilot who was brought under surveillance
for attending and at speaking against
nuclear power before the Dallas City
Council nice little dossier there
running down his Dick Tracy background
in the Marine Corps you know all
straight for those just happen to be
opposed to a nuclear power for those
people who don't know what you're
talking about John this was the guy they
thought might take one of the commercial
airlines and drop it into a nuclear
plant
oh this yeah this finally wound up is
being their justification is well an
airline pilot might dive bomb it into
the nuclear if he's anti-nuke I didn't
mean in retiring yeah I was in the news
couple years ago yeah the file low and
the bps thing started out with criminal
organized crime racial subversive other
and he was checked as being subversive
we've got a copy of the thing over in
our office and part of the lawsuit it's
sort of interesting how DPS left the
agent hanging in terms of personal
liability colonel spear got on the stand
denied a la Mission Impossible and all
of this if you are caught we will deny
any of this stuff and I left the whole
you know saying none of that existed the
whole bit left the agent hanging them
thing so all you agents out there if you
get caught you're going to get left
hanging dangling in the winds let speak
whether some of them might not get
caught but or no excuse me
well the other thing rest about the ACLU
the ACLU asked for its own file and they
ship the first installment in twenty
thousand pages
got him up to 1940 we've got a committee
with our national organization pouring
through that thing it's run up close to
a hundred thousand pages now in terms of
on the organization and on individuals
in the organization one thing I might
add is that if you request your file
from under the Freedom of Information
Act you won't get it all there are large
deletions in your file Stan was cheese
doctor not to be disclosed for national
security reasons you have national
security oh yes in fact they gave me the
reasons and the main reason is not to be
disclosed for national security reasons
and if you do the research there's an
executive order that was issued under
Nixon of setting out the standards of
what constituted national security and
they're things like people that will
disclose information concerning to
foreign agents concerning you know our
bombs and you know things that really
had to do with national security not
someone running around in Austin Texas
talking about a woman's right to an
abortion and there's nothing under the
executive order that would allow the
things that they kept on me or kept from
me in their deletion I hope you all the
viewers of this program understand
exactly what's going on this is a person
who has who believes that women should
have the same rights as the rest of us
who was against an immoral and illegal
war was never declared constitutional in
for this our taxpayer dollars which
could be doing useful things but went
into investigating her and labeling her
and keeping files on her I mean it's
absolutely absurd
I'll give you another example of DPS
okay charter member of the ACLU 94 95
years old now they have $7 Carl Brannon
they had a file on him and they got him
because he was the Socialist Party
candidate for governor in 1936 they had
been following him ever since then it
gets that's silly really it's not so one
of the things that I would say to the
viewers is that the ACLU publishes a
handbook how to get your personal file
it has the law in it the form letters to
the various agencies in which you plug
in your name cite the law the proper
sections
and how to proceed in anybody out there
who thinks that they may have a file and
would be interested in seeing if can
call the American Civil Liberties Union
office here in Austin we can send them a
copy of that process we don't all have
the same expertise apart the other thing
I would say is that if there any lawyers
out there who are interested in
litigation on this area we do publish a
book litigation under the Freedom of
Information Act that's now in its fourth
edition and it has basically all the
pleadings law and the laws you need to
file any sort of Freedom of Information
lawsuit Thanks we've been talking here
about dps and the FBI but we're not
going to let our own local Jean Dom's
off how come
we have with us as I mentioned at the
top of the show Jim Lutz from AC TV took
some extraordinary pictures a film last
year at the boat races on Town Lake and
maybe give us some background in the
film before we see it okay I should go
back probably to when the controversies
first arose several years ago along Town
Lake where the boat races were held it's
on a preview of the Chicano community
and four years or been protesters and
petitioners who have gone before the
City Council to try to have the location
of the races moved to no avail the
previous City Council previous to the
one that is now in session is had voted
to cancel two to keep the boat races
from occurring there in the future and
the new City Council came in and
reinstated the boat races and the
Chicano community members of the Toronto
community banded together to demonstrate
at the location at the date of the first
race or three races each summer and
about a hundred demonstrators on a
Saturday of the of the race last year
came to the races and were met by the
police and it ended in 1810 straight
errs being arrested charged with failure
to obey a lawful order to
out of the street they were standing on
the side of the street off the curb and
if you run the film I could probably you
can see what it looks look at that food
actually okay wasn't it we'll do that
when there's some action the police
action taken against the either one or
some of the police and what was the
outcome and then there wasn't there
grand jury also well there was there was
one officer who you will see in the film
who had who had clubbed one of the
demonstrators who was already being held
this was a good one that night State
this guy he was out of uniform and there
was a supposed to be a federal grand
jury hearing resulting from that from an
investigation that the FBI did and the
federal grand jury was set up for
September which is about four or five
months after the boat races and about a
week before the federal grand jury was
to come off it was cancelled
I've never really heard why I was
canceled and I have a letter here from
the US Justice Department written to mr.
Paul Hernandez who was the acquaintance
and I thought might read the results of
their investigation says after careful
consideration the Civil Rights Division
has concluded that the facts of this
case do not furnish a basis for criminal
prosecution under the federal civil
rights statutes and we are therefore
closing our file on this matter today
let the viewers yet their own conclusion
after they look at the film yes
[Music]
[Music]
Easton's grab my camera as I'm walking
fall straight I'm rusty with him again
reason I just turned off and going
across the street a note poster also hit
the came out from the side down in the
ocean or custodian and welcome to dnews
now the headlines editor knows how to
talk to him however no used to boast
about how we're demonstrator had a
baseball bat it was taken from him early
in the early
no infomercial the public gets they get
the feeling overreacted because after
all the calls are outside after one
[Music]
please the spoon also
his phone
[Music]
just what some people I love you to have
very good relationship some of the
campus police I've had I had a family
coffee and they were absolutely
wonderfully and then just helpful they
put over time
and yet on the other hand you get these
other situations and there are just many
many articles in various magazines of
the police brutality in Seattle Los
Angeles Houston Salt Lake City in Austin
is it that there are a few or many bad
apples that are recruited or is it that
if you hit the wrong button you'll get
the bad reaction
what is it yourself I think a lot of it
is that if you do hit the wrong button
that you get the bad reaction but if you
go politely a lot of them will be pretty
polite if you talk back to them it
triggers something and I don't know what
it is in the mentality of police
officers because is that the legend sort
of reaction but a lot of them do have it
tell so as you mentioned also there's a
last psychology in which they are
against everyone correct but they do
offer under a real operate under real
estate of cos mentality my uncle is a
policeman that works in Brooklyn and
he's had real situations where he's come
up against him when he's called late at
night two o'clock in the morning into a
tenement he has no idea what he's facing
several simple reason killed or killed
during domestics yell exactly most
police officers would rather answer
anything that a domestic disturbance
call right because it most likely to be
injured in that sort of thing
now really put up against it I've talked
about the economic and social causation
of crime never really put in as the
buffers by politicians and who were
failed to deal with the real questions
of wealth and power distribution in this
country they're asked sort of be like
the cavalry guarding over the for the
Indians on the reservation you point
something else' we're not really taking
this whole thing as a condemnation of
our police force we're taking this as a
condensated condemnation of the
violations the abuses by the several
right right and as part of a structure
people usually locust on the police as
individuals
it's a part of the structure it goes if
the department is organized in such a
way that when something like this occurs
that the officer is disciplined you'll
get a whole lot less of that we didn't
have that in the Austin case right and I
don't know what disciplinary actions
were taken against any of those officers
a five-day suspension is hardly what we
call disc um of course with the FBI I
think we can further well condemn the
entire organization I don't think they
prove themselves be too useful in the
past
there goes your dossier just went up
another 15 I've always wanted an
important well you know we see the
enormity of it for instance just in the
Karen Silkwood case where I was counting
from a story that was printed about
Karen Silkwood case she was involved in
or at least they were directly or
indirectly there were 13 private and
public law enforcement agencies or
companies focusing on that one woman
Karen Silkwood and my god this is just a
drop in the bucket compared what it
isn't there are nationwide public and
private organizations which have
dossiers which have computer banks of
names the house and American Activities
Committee when it quit working it turned
things over to Brian assurance industry
had all the earnings back right the
insurance tree has its own computer bank
up in Boston where they keep information
that is available to other corporations
from some of the random searches based
on people who have you know applied for
life insurance this is in David hapgoods
book screening of the average American
track one short comment some of our
viewers may have objected to the title
of our program being the American police
state for sure we don't want to give
anybody the impression that we are a
totalitarian regime like the Soviet
Union but the extent that we do not have
a police state is because the people are
informed and they watch over their
government and they they make sure that
our liberties stay intact profit I don't
to be too dramatic I think it's because
of people like Barbara Jim and John here
that we we do find out about these
violations and abuses I mean the
awareness is the first first step right
this goes back to Thomas Jefferson are
all right to know thank you we want to
thank
being with us and they are increasing
our dossiers all I do have a bedtime
story here which goes back to our
original story talking about the oil
crisis and once again we talk so much
about people and percentages and money
that we well we don't talk about people
enough least the people who are at the
bottom being affected by it the problem
of keeping warm just keeping warm is a
big problem with a lot of people today
The Wall Street Journal had a story
about mrs. Bowers in Lancaster
Pennsylvania she had to move out of her
home because she didn't have enough
money to pay the pay the utility company
- - so they wouldn't turn it off they
estimate there are at least 25 million
many many more other people estimating
two or three times that many who are
below a federal poverty line that can't
even pay these bills at all and mrs.
Bowers is above the poverty line talks
about other people widowed were making
206 dollars a month supporting his
indigent mother and he's cut back to one
meal a day to make sure that his mother
has food and a Pennsylvania woman had
problem she hadn't dealt some of their
furniture in her house and the family
for 50 years in order to just make ends
meet in order to heat their house it's a
tremendous problem however on the other
side here's what the energy consultant
for an investment firm said he said the
oil crisis we must first of all consider
the imponderables and then a spokesman
for the New York Public Service
Commission when asked what they would do
about having some kind of system set up
so they wouldn't cut off the the heating
for people during the winter he said we
don't want to give any deadbeats a
hunting license however mrs. mrs. Bauer
said simply I don't want to leave my
home
but it's hard to keep going I'm only
human and I had to stay warm
maybe we should accent mrs. Bowers
instead of the Public Utilities
Commission let me think about these
problems good night